a military exercise in central Taiwan
a rehearsal for war
that suddenly feels a lot more real
China's been firing warning shots at
this self-governing island making
incursions into Taiwanese airspace
foreign
views it as a breakaway Province it
needs to get back
Taiwan says its military drills are not
a reaction to China's recent moves but
Taiwan also knows in the current climate
it can't take peace for granted
at the presidential office some theater
preparations for Taiwan national day
this year an apparent nod to National
Security the message protects soil guard
country
in the capital Taipei president XI Ying
won is on the campaign Trail
has already said China is disrupting and
threatening the world order
and the invasion of Ukraine has thrust
some civilians into combat training
fearing Taiwan will be the next victim
of an expansionist neighbor trying to
extend its arm of influence
after you're going well with starting is
rising the threat is right thing and
some of us starting to prepare ourselves
what's the stake for Taiwan what could
it lose that one may lose everything in
our democracy in our society the the our
property Our Lives compared with China
taiwan's small and we need to more
friends we need more Airlines and those
allies need to understand the range of
risk according to one man trying to
teach every citizen in Taiwan how to
protect their Community
everything Taiwan is dealing with right
now is beginning to be replicated around
the world right everything Taiwan has
experienced over the last few decades
from China the economic coercion the
intellectual property theft
the interference into our democratic
system into our elections we're seeing
that happening everywhere else
if Taiwan was attacked the supply chain
that runs the world could grind to a
halt the island produces most of the
world's microchips What's Happening Here
is about more than the threat of War
it's about where the balance of power in
the world rests
and that balance of power that's
increasingly fragile
an all-out invasion would take huge
Manpower and money
for now China's pursuit of reunification
seems far more focused on striking fear
than targets Cordelia lent Sky News
Taipei